the david pakman show reddit is
dangerously close to 18,000 subscribers
one of the largest independent media
subreddits on reddit you can find it at
david pakman.com slash our EDD it1
question that is increasingly coming up
in the last 48 hours is about Joe
Biden's cognitive decline which we have
covered alongside Donald Trump's seeming
cognitive decline for months at this
point in time user fun universe asks
does Joe Biden literally have
Alzheimer's
what's his deal pointing out a lot of
the signs and symptoms that we've been
seeing there does seem to be something
going on with Joe Biden and there's been
an attempt to write a lot of it off as
merely Joe Biden's stutter which he's
had his entire life but the truth is if
you look at video of Joe Biden from a
few years ago if you look at video of
Joe Biden debating Paul Ryan back in
2012 if you look video a video of Joe
Biden even just in the 2016 election
talking about Bernie Sanders and Hillary
Clinton and videos about his view on the
primary Joe Biden is very different
today than he was back then and
mistaking his wife and his sister on
Super Tuesday night talking last week
about how he's running for US Senate for
getting quotes mid-sentence there's
there seems to be something going on
with Joe Biden and again much like with
the Donald Trump I don't know how much
definitive we're actually going to get
but this is not an irrational concern I
don't have the answer as to what's going
on much like I don't have it with Donald
Trump but just from the observable
public videos something seems to be
going on does that mean I would choose
Trump over Biden in a general election
of course not and this is why you know
there are questions well actually let's
get to the next reddit thread because
this actually ties into the next
question user Barry Bostwick asked is
there a snowball's chance in hell Biden
picks Bernie for a running mate I think
the answer is obviously no for a lot of
different reasons that are merely
political but the idea of Joe Biden who
himself appears to be experiencing some
cognitive
decline picking another guy who's almost
80 as VP when something more and more
people are talking about is I hope Biden
selects a significantly younger vice
presidential running mate I see it as
extraordinarily unlikely that either
Bernie or Biden would pick the other if
they were to be the eventual Democratic
nominees if you disagree with me let me
know
lastly user misc mouse says Senate be
damned we deserve Medicare for all what
is the likelihood of a Bernie Warren
ticket and unfortunately at this point
the likelihood of that is almost zero
and again the idea has been floated of
Warren's to drop out and endorse Bernie
and as I said earlier I don't think
Warren necessarily wants Bernie to be
the nominee I don't see Warren endorsing
Bernie if she drops out because she
clearly sees the numbers and the
significant likelihood that it's Biden
as the nominee not Bernie if she were to
endorse bernie she would be totally shut
out of a Biden campaign and a possible
Biden presidency and she probably
realizes as do many of her campaign
staff that even if she were to endorse
Bernie
only a fraction of her supporters are
actually going to go in that direction
so I see the likelihood of Biden Bernie
as very low I see the likelihood of
Bernie Warren as extremely low
particularly given the high chance that
Joe Biden is indeed the nominee that's
where I see it right now I invite you to
join the discussion on the subreddit at
david pakman.com slash our EDD IT hit
that free subscribe button we are very
close to 18,000 of our viewers regularly
participating in discussion on the david
pakman show subreddit if you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read you
have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinka splink a-- stakes
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or audiobook that you can get
through in just fifteen minutes where
you're getting all the key takeaways
from the book just imagine how you'll be
able to expand your horizons and
knowledge by being able
to soak up all of the important insights
from ten different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it I recently
read a brief history of time of course
by the great Stephen Hawking this is a
book that I have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was fantastic to check it out on
blinka blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video